Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodassa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So we're carrying on with the candas, these five heaps.
Now, when you look into
the body when you're meditating you can see it's made up first of all of the sensations coming from the body so we did that yes last time the rupa the body and we can break down most of these sensations into these four categories of pressure some sort of weight some sort of
temperature, movement, and some form of cohesiveness, elasticity.
Then there are all these other things that we can feel in the body, feelings that come from the mind that we can describe as emotions.
And thoughts, images.
So that's the Buddha's first three, the rupa, the body, sanya, the perception, and then vedana, feelings.
And tonight we'll do this sanya.
So, in Buddhist psychology, when you attend to something, it will always have a feeling content,
and it will have a perceptive content.
They arise together.
You can't have one without the other.
They're said to be in every moment of attention.
And what the sanya does is it records the basic characteristics of something.
So the zabutons, these mats you're sitting on, the basic thing would be the shape of it, its rectangular shape, and the color.
And it would record that, you see, and these things slowly become your memory.
And by seeing many colors, many shapes, then it begins to discriminate between all the different colors and shapes that you can experience, or that you do experience.
So it's that perceptual memory, you see.
And as it grows to a higher level, then it puts labels on it.
So there's the growth of the intellect coming from the perceptual level, these basic percepts.
And therefore it has the job of recognizing things.
It's your basic memory.
The other factors of a moment of attention you might be interested to know is these two that I've mentioned, the feeling and the perception.
There's also the moment of contact, which I'll come to at another time, which is part of the dependent origination, where you must have an object.
You must have a sense organ and you must have the awareness of it, consciousness.
And remember that there are six sense organs in the Buddha's teaching, the sixth one being the mind itself.
The base of that presumably is the brain, the brain itself.
Then there is will.
There must be some power there.
within that moment just keeping things together and pointing them and then there's that one pointedness of attention it's a quality then there's that quality of attending which is best expressed in that sentence to pay attention it's actually a quality
and it's called mental life faculty.
That's just the basic energy, the basic mental energy.
And it is said that all these seven factors, mental factors are within any given moment of attention.
Now, what happens is that the
quality of these perceptions join with the emotional base and then through the act of will, through that act of attending you get this creativity and at worst it's known as papancha which is a lovely word which means proliferation.
and your mind's going all over the place.
But at its more important level, it's the growth of the conceptual mind, the growth of thinking, and eventually of philosophy and the arts.
So that all begins from that particular perceptual base of sanya.
So we're still really investigating these khanda, the five aggregates into which the Buddha dissected our experience.
So it's the body with its sensations, sanya which were the perceptual faculties which grow into concepts, our intellect.
Today I want to talk about vedana which is feeling.
The fourth was Sankara, which just loosely we can sometimes translate as volitional conditioning, so it's where the will comes in.
And then finally our act of cognition or consciousness.
So just looking at Vedana, so there are
five types and it's a slightly different way of looking at things.
Two of them are physical.
That's pretty straightforward for us.
We have pleasant and unpleasant sensations.
That's pretty easy for us to distinguish.
But there's also distinguished as pleasant and unpleasant mental sensations and that's where the confusion comes in because normally speaking we talk about feelings and emotions.
and I think they shade into each other emotions are very complex things but when you just go into the body they manifest as some sort of feeling
depression is heavy, anger is hot and all that and that's what we're looking at when we are just feeling a sensation in the body which we recognize is caused by a mental state rather than the body itself and it's distinguishing those two and the fifth one is of course the neutral states of both the body sensations and the mental sensations
And the reason we distinguish those two is because the Buddha taught that the physical part of our nature and the mental part were two actually distinct forms of energy.
They both suffered from impermanence, they don't constitute a self or a soul or a person, but they are two different energy systems, the one affecting the other.
And you're sitting when you get a sore knee, the mind becomes agitated.
If you feel depressed, then the mind becomes heavy.
Or if you feel tired, the body becomes heavy.
So that distinguishing, that deconstructing of our experience is part and parcel of understanding
that this psycho-physical organism that we experience ourselves to be does not actually constitute an entity as such, something which is whole, entire, self-subsistent, can exist outside this universe, all that sort of stuff.
It just isn't that.
And you can also, he also splits it up again, dissects it again into the various feelings that arise from the six, well seven senses.
So sight, what we see is also a sensation, it also comes under the physical feelings.
Hearing, what we hear comes under physical feelings, bodily feelings.
So by dividing that, then of course we can see that there are something like 30 different types of sensations and feelings.
These are only types, as you know, within each type there are myriad types of feelings and sensations.
And I dare say, it's never the case that one is exactly the same as the other, like leaves on a tree, they're not the same.
The other thing to say about Vedana is that they're always in any level of consciousness.
So whenever you're conscious, there has to be the factor of Vedana.
So if you're seeing, there's the feeling or sensation of light.
If you're hearing, there's the sensation of sound and so on.
So it's not possible for there to be a conscious moment without there being some sort of feeling.
Now the importance of Vedana
The way he separates this out, feeling, comes up in the discourse on how to establish this right mindfulness, which is about seeking liberation, the Satipaṭṭhāna discourse.
And there's a second section there, after physical feelings, bodily feelings,
there comes vedana-vedanupāsati which means to see feelings in feelings it's a sort of funny construction it's what's known as a locative case where you're in something so it's to feel, to see, to experience feelings in feelings now that seems like a double take
But all he's saying is to try and separate out feelings completely from perceptual things, from emotional fantasies and stuff, and to just center completely on feeling.
What is a feeling?
To ask yourself the question, what is a feeling?
What is a sensation?
because normally speaking we don't experience life in this way we just experience it in the fullness of our personality and physical contact with the world but by doing so it's all part and parcel of seeing how this life works for us and the
This confusion between emotion and feeling, when I say confusion it's the English and it's the way that we experience things, is something that we deal with when we come to the Sankara, which is the next section to do with the will.
So then it becomes quite complicated because everything then begins to motor up into what we would consider an experience.
So that, short and sweet, is the description of Vedana.
I hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you be fully liberated from all your painful Vedana, sooner rather than later.